Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie
And it looks like we might be getting a Star Wars
style
What if
Series
Exploring different scenarios,
different timelines based on the movies,
the other shows in different parts of the timeline.
A lot of you been theorizing
that they do something like this for a while.
So we'll break it all down in my top ten Star Wars.
What if scenarios for them to explore right now?
if you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
is a bunch of big stuff coming up.
We have X-Men 97 episodes.
there's a couple of Star Wars series
that'll be happening this year, too, like Star Wars
Skeleton Crew, which is connected to The Mandalorian
and all those shows and the Star Wars acolytes series.
But they didn't list a release date for this Star Wars.
What if series
or whether or not it'd be live action or animated?
My assumption is animated just like the Marvel
whatever series.
Just because the stuff you're dealing with
like you want to do really, really big stories.
And it's harder to do that in live action,
like the budget would have to be $1,000,000,000.
the funny thing to a lot of you, longtime
Star Wars comic book
readers from back in the expanded Universe
era now called the Legends Era, will remember
that Star Wars has already done
what if series a couple different times?
They just call it something different.
they even legitimately based some of their video games
on the whole, what if concept?
the whole premise of the force.
Unleash in the Starkiller a character, Sam Witwer
His character is based on a what if scenario
is essentially an alternate timeline for Star Wars
that starts after the end of Revenge of the Sith
in order 66 basically after the events of Order 66,
you have the great Jedi Purge where Darth Vader starts
going around the galaxy with the new Imperial Army,
the now Stormtroopers,
they're still clone troopers just in stormtrooper
looking armor.
beginning to kill all the Jedi
that he can find around the galaxy.
in one of his early engagements,
he goes to Koushik looking for more Jedi to kill
and winds up killing Galen Merrick's father
in a lightsaber battle, then finds him, learns
that he's for sensitive, and decides
to train him as his apprentice, basically becoming
what would eventually turn into the inquisitors,
like the prototype for inquisitors.
But because when they introduce
the Starkiller character a long time ago,
they hadn't created the concept of inquisitors
in the Star Wars universe yet.
So. Sam Witwer talks about this whole phenomenon
the concept of Starkiller as an inquisitor.
Like his potential role
and how it would fit in the canon.
Well, I know that, Dave, at one point
when you were doing Star Wars rebels
thought about including him as an inquisitor.
the son of a Jedi
and that he, in the Inquisitor aureus,
had a personal connection with Vader,
that maybe he was an inquisitor,
that Vader was secretly training on the side
as an apprentice
Essentially, Starkiller was the first inquisitor
before the inquisitors existed.
there were the Star Wars infinite comic book series.
Like a lot of dark horse comics dealt with the
what if concept in different ways.
Star Wars.
Infinite was a trilogy of stories based on
what if scenarios
for the original trilogy of movies,
A New Hope, Empire Strikes Back, Return of the Jedi.
Like what if things had gone down very differently?
there was even an official Lucasfilm
comic book crossover between Indiana Jones
and Star Wars, where Indiana Jones discovers
the Millennium Falcon.
It was super dark to there was even an eight part
miniseries called the Star Wars,
which was another alternate timeline
retelling of the entire saga
based on George Lucas's
original rough draft for the script for Star Wars,
which they had found in the Lucasfilm archives
while researching other projects.
in in George Lucas's original rough draft
for Star Wars, all the characters were very different.
Like, all the names were different whole plot details,
secondary characters were very different.
Like it felt like a completely different type
of series, which they based this whole miniseries on.
so Star Wars is not new to the whole
What if concept is just that the closest they've gotten
to doing that in video form is the actual video games
like the Force unleashed games.
Right.
Now, my top ten Star Wars
what if scenarios are what if and again,
Skywalker had the high ground this is a pretty obvious
one killed Obi-Wan Kenobi on Mustafar.
they actually did this in an alternate ending timeline
during the Revenge of the Sith video game
adaptation of the movie.
Back when that came out on PS two,
where Anakin kills Obi-Wan, eventually kills
the emperor becoming emperor himself
and it's still a pretty dark ending.
Like he doesn't turn back to the light side.
He just becomes emperor.
What if Asoka
never left the Jedi order and never left in a can side?
She often blames herself in present day for
and against fall to the dark side like it
weighs heavily on her because he'd been so isolated
in his final years before order 66 happened,
leaving a way more vulnerable to the Emperor's
psychological manipulation.
So the idea is that had Asoka stayed by his side, it's
implied he never would have fallen to the dark side.
They would have been able to prevent order 66
prevent the empire from rising preventing.
PADMÉ From dying,
meaning Aniket would have also been alive to raise Luke
and Leia with PADMÉ As a traditional family.
what if Darth Vader survived
the events of Return of the Jedi after his redemption?
So the idea is, after regaining the trust
of the rebellion in that period, right
before The Mandalorian picks up Mon Mothma, Leia,
the eventual ruling Senate in the New Republic,
he would have probably been
a much more effective commander, helping them root out
the rest of the imperial remnant much, much quicker
so that the Shadow Council never rises.
Thrawn
never becomes the threat that he does in present day.
Right now,
the whole first order would have been destroyed
before they could finish their experiments
in cloning the Emperor.
So the Emperor would have stayed dead and they wouldn't
have been able to create their new fleet
and they would have been able to destroy Exegol
that Sith planet.
What if Mace Windu survived the fall?
This would pay off probably one of the longest
running theories in the fandom that he's still alive
out there somewhere.
You have him returned during the events
of the Mandalorian timeline to help them fight Thrawn
the Knights sisters give Grogu to some more force
teachings.
would have been solo never fell to the dark side.
Luke Skywalker would have never tried to kill him
at his Jedi Academy.
Also, it would have never led to him
seeking out Snoke the first order helping their rise.
He would have never fought Luke later,
leading to Luke's death.
What if Grogu had chosen Yoda's light saber
instead of the Mandalorians Beskar chainmail shirt
going back with him essentially.
What if Grogu had stayed with Luke Skywalker
and become his first real apprentice?
even though in reality he left Luke,
I still think that Grogu will become just as powerful,
if not more powerful than Yoda someday, even
without all that training at Luke's Academy.
But he would have become way more powerful, way faster.
And then you think about
what happened with Kylo Ren, the Knights of Ren
coming back to kill all the students at the academy.
Would this mean that Grogu would have also been killed
by the Knights of Ren?
so. Isn't it a little bit better
that Grogu, who did eventually leave Luke Skywalker?
What if Asoka followed Enoch and Skywalker
to the dark side of the force?
This is essentially
What if Asoka became a Sith, just like.
And again, she would have become a special inquisitor
working with him.
They would have been powerful enough
to find and kill Obi-Wan Kenobi.
also Ahsoka was instrumental in helping the fledgling
rebellion rise during the dark times before a new hope.
That's why she was called Fulcrum.
Like she helped with their communications early on, me.
That if she hadn't been doing that, the rebellion
wouldn't have been able to come together fast enough.
Darth Vader.
His new Sith Apprentice.
Asoka the Emperor would have crushed them.
What if Obi-Wan had a child with Duchess satin?
during the Obi-Wan Kenobi series,
they had teasers for another Kenobi being out there.
He said he had a family who were still alive, out
somewhere in the galaxy.
they could always explore that in a future series.
But despite all the fan theories about him
having a potential child with Duchess, the team
like them actually having a real relationship.
Most of the things that the Star Wars people have said
have actually thrown some water on this idea,
But I don't think that anybody from Lucasfilm,
like Dave Filoni
or anybody official, has ever come out and said, no,
absolutely not.
There's
no way that Obi-Wan Kenobi ever had any children.
what if PADMÉ survived
Revenge of the Sith and raised Luke and Leia herself?
She would have been around to not only guide them,
but also help lead the rebellion
and help it form way faster.
And because the Empire wouldn't have been able to lie
to Darth Vader
and twist him even darker with the idea that he killed
PADMÉ and the twins himself,
it would have been way easier for PADMÉ
to help turn him back to the light side
before the events of a new Hope.
in probably my number one,
what if scenario for them to explore would be
what if Darth Vader took an apprentice,
which is basically them doing Star Killer with Sam
Witwer during those games or even a couple of what
if scenarios like alternate timelines
depending on the choices you made.
So there was a light side ending in a dark side ending,
depending on who
you kill at the end, either Darth Vader or the Emperor.
really just want to see Starkiller at some point show
up in some of the TV shows of the movies somewhere.
as far as I know, though.
This What if Star Wars series is just in development?
It doesn't mean it'll actually wind up getting made.
There's a lot of Star Wars stuff
like movies, TV shows that are in development
that will probably never see the light of day.
The ground is littered with the bones of Star Wars
movies that Lucasfilm announced
but never wound up making,
probably the closest thing to like another anthology
type of series that they'd done recently,
especially in animation, is the Star Wars
Visions Series, or even Tales of the Jedi tells
the Jedi felt like it could have been a really cool
what if series, but it's all meant to be Canon stories.
that's the only real difference is
it's all stuff that happened to different characters
in different parts of the timeline.
so hopefully in future seasons of Tales of the Jedi,
we'll actually see some brand new characters
that they're introducing on the Mandalorian.
Really good example is Balan School.
Wouldn't you like to see a young version
of Balan school when he was still part of the Jedi
Order during Tales of the Jedi
speaking of which, we are supposed to get Tales
of the Jedi season two later this year,
but I don't know exactly when that's going to air.
I believe that the Star Wars
Skeleton Crew series with Jude Law is going to be
the next live action series to air.
We should get a trailer for that
in the next couple of months.
But they didn't say exactly when it's going to release.
Of course,
I will do videos for whatever they wind up dropping
I believe the Star Wars
acolyte series is coming towards the end of the year.
That'll be during a completely different part
of the timeline.
It's High Republic era.
I don't know what their future plans
are for high Republic stuff generally.
Right now all the movie announcements
they just made for like the Grogu movie,
the Thrawn movie is all Mandalorian stuff
taking precedence first.
But as far as I know, there haven't been any kind
of movie announcements during the high Republic era.
I think they're just kind of waiting to see how
everybody responds to all the live action stuff there.
I've already done a skeleton crew trailer
for all the footage they released earlier.
Click here for all that and click here for that
brand new Ahsoka Season two teaser.
Thank you so much for watching
and I'll see you guys in the next one!